so I saw all this man running and all  the direction people just in front here  under the table and that people should  now been abatements f was in his  daughter's apartment watching the  football if it hadn't been on he'd have  been downstairs in the bath it's like  war what crazy he's a surgeon and he's  from Tunisia these people must not win  they make so many problems all over the  world you must be together  they kill our child innocent people 1820  down set here it's awful lazy people  killing people like this they're not  human nobody can do things like this war  is stupid but you have solar in front of  you but here you have child sitting  drinking it's off